um yeah I mean I think one thought to
add to that is that when we've been
thinking about how to you know present
the story and message the film we've
we've always kind of tended towards
rather than trying to say that
anything's wrong or that anything is
negative we've really been focusing on
sort of like that there's this really
awesome interesting alternative that's
interesting for all these different
reasons you know from a design
perspective and from a creative
perspective and you know and really kind
of just focusing on that because we feel
like you know if we can get people
engaged on that level rather than trying
to like pick apart anyone's life and say
that it's wrong I mean we don't really
want to spend time doing that or go
there so but it is an interesting bounds
because it's for me because I'd totally
agree with everything Brad said you know
but i also like I feel like you know in
order to be a real to make a difference
you almost have to be a challenging
provocative kind of filmmaker in a way
because you don't want to you know try
to refrain from alienating people so
much that you're not actually saying
anything and so it's interesting balance
to it you know an interesting line to
walk and it's hard to find a balance
sometimes and just how hard to push it
without being pushing it too far you
know that it's saying like you know
there is something wrong with society
not necessarily you but maybe the way
that like we're doing things as a whole
or something like that and to say that
in a way that's not threatening and not
judgmental an accusatory especially
individuals but but to still challenge
people to think differently about what's
possible so for the film in keeping with
that have you tried to just really keep
it to your own personal story so that
people don't feel like you're being too
preachy with it is that how you've tried
to hone in your message yeah and I think
I mean in interviewing all these
different people who have gone through
the process of downsizing for different
reasons that those issues come up you
know I think organically from you know
people talk about how they were in debt
because they you know they felt like
they had to live one kind of lifestyle
and they really
they didn't and so I think you know that
the issues are coming out of the stories
of the people that are profiling and out
of our story without having to do too
much sort of like you know sort of like
generalizing or things like that
definitely and I think part of us to
move to expanding the film into a
feature length is because we wanted to
devote some time to be critical actually
of the tiniest movement in critical of
our own story in a way that makes it
more you know come complexities and more
so we're not trying to sell this simple
idea and say oh yeah it's totally
possible for everybody to live this way
and there's no problems with it and and
it's your fault for not doing it without
being realistic about you know like many
people who live in tiny houses do so
because they come from a place of
privilege you know they they have the
ability to choose you know where they
live or how they live if there's a
little you know there are plenty of
criticisms about the tiny house movement
that are worth bringing up in addressing
and so I think maybe by expanding it to
a feature in doing that people won't
feel like we we haven't do it done or do
due diligence and we're just you know
kind of shooting from the hip and
attacking without really thinking about
it being you know think critically about
the issue
you